aloha banjo nos bonnes journées comment
vous allez aujourd'hui on va se parler
d'astuces iphone oui ça fait un petit
moment que je n'ai pas fait et je me
suis dit que ça pourrait être
sympathique de se regarder des petites
astuces pour l'iphone pour savoir
comment optimiser l'utilisation de votre
iphone comment mieux l'utiliser au
quotidien vous montrer des astuces que
vous ne connaissez a priori pas
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je compte sur vous
pour me dire des leurs en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous les
connaissiez ou alors est-ce que vous ne
les connaissez pas vous êtes prêt on
sait les astuces c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec aide comme m
com est un site comparateur de
smartphones deux forfaits mobiles et
d'internet
si vous êtes en quête de bons plans pour
venir trouver votre nouveau smartphone
votre forfait internet ou votre forfait
de téléphone est bien là vous avez une
bonne adresse être com vous propose pas
moins de trois outils différents vous
avez un comparateur de forfaits mobiles
forfaits sans engagement pas cher
illimité ou forfait 5 g il vous permet
d'évaluer les offres de 15 opérateurs au
travers de différents critères que sont
le prix le volume internet la durée les
engagements et les différents réseaux
mais vous venir également trouver votre
forfait internet une offre box pas cher
une box internet on promo de la fibre
optique ou alors carrément internet tout
seul vous et pouvoir venir comparez pas
moins de sept fournisseurs et vous aurez
accès ici à plein d'offres hyper
intéressante mais sur est comme vous
avez également un comparateur de
smartphones pour me retrouver le
smartphone de vos rêves vous pouvez
venir filtrer selon le prix la marque
l'état neuf ou reconditionnés
mais également la taille de l'écran et
si vous recherchez un modèle en
particulier
et bien vous n'avez qu'à l' tapez ici et
vous avez trouvé le smartphone de vos
rêves par exemple un iphone 12 je clique
dessus je vois ici la meilleure offre et
je peux bien filtrée l'état la capacité
et même choisir la couleur mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là puisque d'autres comme
c'est également un blog d'actualité qui
vous permettra de suivre tous les sujets
les lancements de produits les promos
opérateurs mais également un guide qui
vous fournira des conseils les astuces
pour le télétravail la résiliation de
votre contrat ou bien encore savoir quoi
faire quand votre téléphone tombe dans
l'eau et comme a décidé de vous faire un
très joli cadeau en vous offrant un
iphone 12 128 giga de stockage avec un
abonnement à prixtel de un an avec le
plus gros forfaits à 19,99 par mois pour
participer c'est très facile vous avez
toutes les modalités qui sont en bas
dans la description le lien je vous
invite bien évidemment à cliquer dessus
à découvrir être comme et à tenter votre
chance pour gagner votre iphone 12 128
giga et ça et ça c'est une très très
bonne nouvelle
on se met directement dans le vif du
sujet regardez j'ai pas mal d'astuces à
vous montrer sur mon iphone là on va
bien ou mais regardez alors regarder ce
qu'il ya c'est super intéressant
la toute première savez des petits
raccourcis pour venir accéder à vos
différents réglages par exemple vous
voulez accéder à vos réglages vous
appuyez dessus ensuite vous venez
chercher dans votre menu ce que vous
voulez le wifi sied ça et ça c'est un
peu galère il ya beaucoup plus simple
pour les réglages vous allez utiliser
très régulièrement voulait s'appuyer
dessus
et là vous voyez que vous avez vos
réglages qui vient
paraître bluetooth wifi données
cellulaires batterie ce sera exactement
la même chose avec d'autres applications
notamment google photo voulait s'appuyer
j'ai de la chance libérer l'espace créé
un album pour la météo c'est pareil ici
pour la chaîne météo je peux voir
exactement où est ce que j'en suis la
même chose pour mon appareil-photo
prendre selphy enregistré une vidéo
prendra portrait prendre un portrait en
selle fille absolument pareil pour mes
emails je laisse appuyé je peux faire un
nouveau message très rapidement sans
avoir à l'ouvrir
donc ces petites astuces là elles sont
toutes sympa pas très compliqué voiliers
mais on les connaissait pas forcément
des redites moi vous en commentaire est
ce que vous le connaissiez ou alors
absolument pas autre astuce lorsque vous
voulez envoyer un message et que vous
naviguez que vous voulez pas galérer
alors je vous montez un truc est très
très simple et qui est vachement bien
lorsque vous venez taper un message mais
je n'en sais rien vous allez m coucou
toi vous sautez vous tapez des trucs
vous retaper des trucs vous retaper des
trucs bon vous tapez plein de trucs vous
devenez un petit peu fou dingue ça votre
clavier vous tapez tellement truc vous
voulez pas galérer à venir naviguer ici
et d'ailleurs tout est très simple
voulait s'appuyer espaces et ça vous
fait un petit pas pour venir naviguer
tarifs sinon regardez vous venez
naviguer vous pouvez venir
exactement où vous voulez et ça c'est
vraiment génial
alors vous l'avez ici dans les messages
ne vous l'avait également ailleurs par
exemple dans vos notes là j'ai un très
grand axe qui écrit je viens édité ma
note
eh bien je fais exactement la même chose
je laisse appuyé sur la barre
d'espacement je viens naviguer très
facilement dans ma note je vais où je
veux et ça et ça c'est vraiment super
cool
il ya un autre truc qui est assez
intéressant lorsque par exemple vous
allez vous coucher le soir et que vous
avez peur que la personne à côté de vous
si vous dormez à côté ou je sais pas
vous êtes dans un dans un gîte avec
plein de gens autour de vous avez peur
qu'on prenne votre iphone et conviennent
le déverrouiller pendant que vous dormez
ou que vous avez peur qu'on vous force à
le déverrouiller comme ça il ya une
petite astuce un petit hack est très
rapide vous allez voir qu'il va venir
vous sécurisez qui la vie en gros blocs
if i said i vous êtes obligés de venir
taper votre code pour déverrouiller
regarder il vous suffit de prendre votre
iphone une fois qu'il est verrouillé et
de venir appuyer appui long sur le
bouton pour l'allumer potins et appui
long sur le bouton de volume bas alors
normalement ça c'est le raccourci pour
venir l'éteindre mais ce que ça va faire
lorsque vous annulez là et bien failli
sadi ne marchera plus on va venir vous
demander votre code
un autre truc est très rigolo si vous
voulez écrire un message directement
avec vos petites mimines
au lieu d'envoyer un sms avec lé
caractère classique et bien c'est très
facile
vous venez ici dans votre application de
messages vous le prenez
vous le faites pivoter comme ça et ici
en bas ça vous ouvre ses petites parties
qui vont permettre de venir écrire votre
texte un bon vieux coucous ça marchera
toujours vous faites
ok et là vous voyez qu'il est prêt à
partir vous avez qu'appuyer il part
directement à ces pratiques autre astuce
qui peut bien vous sauver la vie si par
exemple vous avez dans votre entourage
quelqu'un qui doit pouvoir vous
contacter anne n'a pour le moment du
jour et de la nuit j'en sais rien moi si
par exemple jean castex veut que
emmanuel macron plus le contact et à
n'importe quel du moment du jour et de
la nuit
et bien il a une petite option à venir
actionnez ici dans son smartphone dans
son iphone pour pouvoir être joint à
n'importe quel moment je vous montre
vous venez dans votre répertoire qui est
ici dans vos contacts là par exemple je
suis sur la fiche de roxy j'ai calé ici
d'en modifier ensuite je vais dans
sonneries et ensuite revenir cocher la
case priorité en cas d'urgence écrit à
priorité en cas d'urgence autorise les
sons et les vibrations provenant de sept
personnes même lorsque le bouton
sonnerie étant silencieux ou lorsque ne
pas déranger tactile est ce qui fait que
roxy peut maintenant appeler à n'importe
quel moment on voit la pratique
autre astuce que je trouve vraiment très
très pratique alors moi j'ai des tonnes
de photos qui sont tout le temps sur mon
smartphone parce que pour mon table je
fais des photos tout le temps je me
prends en photo ici ailleurs j'ai quinze
fois la même photo et il ne faut
regarder que cette astuce va vous
permettre de venir effacés plein de
photos rapidement sans galérer son
devoir les sélectionner une par une ces
rapidement la galère est d'autant plus
que quand on voit que ce que coûte
aujourd'hui le stockage dans le cloud
là pour le coup il ya un vrai usage plus
plus plus alors je vous montre vous êtes
dans votre application de photos ici moi
notamment google photos vous voyez que
des photos avec ma tronche il y en a un
paquet alors ce qu'on vient ferme
allemand on vient appuyer ici et on
vient les sélectionner une par une pour
venir les supprimer il ya fait beaucoup
plus simple vous en sélectionner une ope
là par exemple ici et je laisse mon
doigt appuyé et ensuite je glisse et ça
me sélectionne tout ce que je veux juste
que je veux donc ça c'est vachement bien
très pratique
donc quand vous voulez regarder qu'une
seule et virait tout le reste vous
n'avez qu'à venir déplacer votre doigt
et ça c'est hyper hyper hyper cool autre
astuce vous êtes souvent des marchés par
de la publicité je ne sais pas d
assurance qui veulent vous appelez que
si que ça des personnes que vous ne
connaissez pas cherche à vous joindre
et il ya un moment où il y en a qui
pleurent à la casquette alors une astuce
très sain pour justement de plus être
importuné dans votre iphone vous allez
dans vos réglages et dans vos réglages
vous allez sur téléphone téléphone
téléphone téléphone téléphone est ici
vous le voyez vous avez appel d'inconnus
silencieux ici c'est non je clique
dessus et là je peux venir active et ça
ce qui fait que les appels d'inconnus de
personnes que je ne connais pas
bien seront silencieux et savent où les
cris les appels des numéros inconnus
seront silencieux envoyé vers la
messagerie est affichée dans la liste
des appels récents l'appareil continuera
de fonctionner pour les appels entrants
de vos contacts des personnes que vous
avez appelé récemment ou celles issues
des suggestions de syrie donc si vous
êtes des marchés par n'importe qui
n'importe comment et bien vous n'allez
plus être importuné ça c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle
un autre point qui peut faire râler
certaines personnes c'est le fait de
voir la lumière de votre iphone changer
en fonction des conditions de luminosité
oui forcément si vous êtes dehors il ya
un grand soleil eh bien il va venir
pousser la luminosité à fond pour vous y
avait quelque chose il a contrario dans
une pièce très sombre il va venir
baisser la lumière pour venir protéger
vos yeux et rallonger la durée de vie de
votre batterie
mais si vous voulez venir régler vous ça
directement sans votre iphone prennent
le contrôle et bien c'est complètement
possible je vous montre et je sais pas
si vous le saviez ailleurs dit le manga
en commentaire il vous faut aller dans
vos réglages dans vos réglages vous
allez dans accessibilité d'accessibilité
vous allez dans un fichage et taille de
texte et vous allez tout en bas dans
luminosité automatique
la désactivation du réglage de
luminosité automatique peut diminuer la
durée de vie de la batterie est affecté
les performances d'affichage à long
terme ça il faut le savoir
mais si vous voulez vous avoir la main
dessus vous faites ça et on si vous
allez venir régler ici directement bon à
voir ce qui est le plus pratique le plus
intéressant mais moi je vous conseille
quand même pour prolonger la durée vie
de votre batterie est bien de venir à
l'activer c'est quand même mieux
un autre point qui est super intéressant
si par exemple eh bien vous voulez
envoyer un message avec un point
d'exclamation en point d'interrogation
ou un caractère spécial
mais vous n'avez pas envie de galérer
dans vos différents menus regardé comme
par exemple je vais mettre ça va avec un
point d'interrogation vous devez venir
appuyer sur un deux trois points
d'interrogation revenir là est bon il ya
un moment ça va cinq minutes alors au
lieu de faire ça fait leur truc est très
simple vous laisse à 2 puis 1 2 3 vous
allez sur le point d'interrogation vous
lever et ça vous ramène directement sur
votre clavier pour venir taper et ça
c'est super simple très pratique cela
fait gagner un temps dingue et ça
évident à payer 15 fois sur le 1 2 3 il
ya un moment où on est un petit peu
marre autre astuce super cool si vous
êtes en train de taper un texte et que
tout s'efface parra a par erreur vous
l'avez pas fait exprès par exemple je
sais pas moi vous tapez des trucs là
vous tapez vous tapez vous tapez vous
tapez vous tapez vous tapez vous venez
tous sélectionnés ici et vous supprimez
et vous vous dites masse j'ai tout
supprimer eh ben il ya tout qui est
hyper simple vous venez secouez votre
iphone annulé la saisie
oui et il vous remet tout directement
tels que c'était juste avant coup vous
pouvez souffler tout va bien voilà ça
viendra peut-être vous sauver la vie
quand vous est un atout qui s'efface
vous secouer le téléphone comme si elle
revient revient revient et ben c'est
quand même pas mal
petite astuce qui est tout bête mais qui
est très sympa lorsque vous venez
naviguer dans une carte et que vous
voulez venir zoomer dézoomer sans
galérer avec le petit pin's comme ça et
que vous dois pinch to zoom et bientôt
qui est très simple regardez ce que vous
faites c'est que vous tapez une fois
vous posez votre doigt et là en glissant
boon et zoomer dézoomer zoomer dézoomer
zoomer dézoomer c'est super simple vous
venez glisser votre doigt au plat vous
vous déplacez vous appuyer pour appuyer
et là vous vous des zooms et dézoomer
plat j'appuie hop là zoomer dézoomer je
me déplace jura puis zoomer dézoomer
c'est vachement bien c'est pratique
c'est une autre façon de venir naviguer
un devoir s'endetter sans devoir prendre
votre deuxième main et venir zoomer
dézoomer comme ça voyez vous prenez un
doigt vous appuyez et hop là fait la
même chose
très pratique autre astuce qui a tout
juste d'arriver avec ios 14.5 c'est le
fait de ne plus être traqués de ne plus
être suivie notamment par facebook et
instagram
je vous montez journée déjà parlé sur
youtube regardez ça c'est assez
intéressant il faut que vous veniez ici
dans vos réglages vous allez dans
confidentialité et dans confidences été
vous allez dans suivi et il faut que
cette petite case la soie décoché pour
autoriser le demande des suivis des apps
donc si elle est décochée vous
n'autorisez pas les applications à vous
suivre si vous la cocher vous autorisez
les applications tierces à venir vont
suivre à faire un tracking alors
attention il faut réfléchir à savoir ce
qu'on veut faire ici parce que ce
tracking permet d'avoir des outils et
des services gratuits financés par la
publicité grâce à vos données
personnelles qui sont recueillies grâce
au tracking publicitaire est de la
publicité ciblée à savoir si vous
soutenez la publicité ciblée ou si vous
la soutenez pas si vous êtes prêts à
payer pour certains services ou pas
voilà il faut se poser cette question
mais en tout cas si vous voulez vous
pouvez le faire et la dernière astuce
voulait déjà présenté également sur
youtube c'est le fait de venir
déverrouiller son iphone avec son masque
enfin c'est une nouvelle fonctionne et
est qu'ils arrivent également grâce à
ios 14.5 c'est pas idéal parce que vous
devez utiliser et avoir une apple watch
pour pouvoir le faire mais si vous
voulez on peut le faire alors regardez
je vous montre c'est très facile vous
venir chercher ici
fayçal dix écoles regardez c'est noté
justice if i said i et codes
là ils me demandent mon code bon je le
tape je vous demande pas mais je le tape
ensuite il faut que vous descendiez et
que vous veniez cochez cette case là
c'est à dire
déverrouillez avec l'apple watch ça
permettra effectivement devenir
déverrouiller directement avec votre
apple watch comme on peut le faire avec
des mac
si vous avez l'habitude et que vous avez
un agv ou déverrouiller votre mac avec
votre apple watch vous avez l'apple
match au poignet elle reconnaît mme
mackels déverrouiller c'est exactement
la même chose ici
à savoir que si je le désactive j'ai
beau avoir mon apple watch au poignet et
bien j'en mets mon masque jette un truc
il reconnaît pas il veut pas je retourne
ici d'en-face heidi et codes
moi je retape mon code c'est fastidieux
mais bon faut sécuriser un petit peu je
l'autorisent jeu l'activent ici je
prends mon smartphone je me mets en face
et lime marque directement sur maman de
voiliers iphone de aurélien
déverrouiller par cet appel watch donc
ça c'est vachement bien c'est très
pratique alors voilà pour ces petites
astuces je sais pas lesquels vous
connaissiez ce que vous en avez d'autres
à partager bien évidemment vous pouvez
me le marquer en bas en commentaire
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo dites
moi si ça vous intéresse qu on fasse
plein de petites vidéos d'astuces de
temps en temps pour voir les bonnes
astuces que ce soit sur un os que ce
soit sur android que ce soit sur même
des des surcouches particulière on
affine sur when your eyes on a parlé sur
color os est ce que vous voulez que vous
donne plus d'astuces pour mieux utiliser
votre smartphone mark et moi ça bien
évidemment en bas au commentaire quant à
moi je vous embrasse beaucoup d'amour et
n'oubliez pas de venir participer aux
jeux avec être comme le lien qui fait
plus en bas dans la description des
bisous il ya très vite ciao